cette ses derniers moments c'est lui
jacques content vous êtes content ambre
à la normale sans toujours stressé quand
même quand ils arrivent là ils perdent
tout
et du coup quand ils sont libres ben ils
ont tout pouvoir faire
pouvoir commencer
donc
c'est le moment le plus stressant quoi
c'est pour ça qu'il y en a aussi
qui retourne en prison c'est plus simple
oui la base
bon
on vous revoit plus quoi
ok bon combat au revoir
[Musique]
salubre huit mois c'est luc et je suis
surveillants pénitenciers fait montrer
mon quotidien dans une maison d'arrêt en
prison
[Musique]
au niveau des procédures pour les allées
sont fait mal ou peu importe elle m'a
passé c'était un client américain pour
le genou il vous plaît a bien droit sur
pied un peu louche aller chercher un
autre accès et quand on entre dans le
métier forcément ses goûts y avoir des
agressions des soucis d des engueulades
avec des détenus enfin j'aime bien dire
c'est un peu comme une télé réalité ce
qu'on ait h 24 avec les détenus les
surveillants et dix fois on s'engueule
avec les détenus lendemain sans oublier
on s'engage avec un autre détenu
à l'ouverture a parlé à emma à merci
[Musique]
ouais enfin stressant vigilant parce que
c'est là où ils peuvent ils avaient plus
de risques pour l'instant
de se faire sauter dessus agressé c'est
pour ça qu'on fait à plusieurs
bonjour
tu vois ça met un peu bell ca voilà
merci
bonjour
en bas
[Musique]
avant ça je travaillais dans le
fast-food et après j'ai changé pour
travailler dans la grande distribution
et c'est là que ça m'a permis on va dire
de rentrer dans la pénitentiaire ce que
du coup j'ai pris un caractère
[Musique]
c'est pas vous qui décidez trois jours
s'il y en ait décidé si moi non je les
aime pas on peut aussi être un peu je
vous jure que si j'en sais des cellules
royan nahd mais si je pense à le dire tu
restes là laitages tous eu tout le temps
qu ils veulent une semaine surveillance
est juste une semaine si vous mettez un
excellent choix difficiles et je sais ça
fait partie du budget je prends de l'âge
et j'affirme que je veux ça on essaie
d'adapter les gens sont maintenant
sommés prenons jada freddy sylvain
armand est sûre ça c'est comme avec
maven y avait 13 ans sourire et alors
que me reste un
break et elle est marraine cette forme
et surveille je lui explique que c'est
bon on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut
c'est le chef qui décide et que une
mutation à ça se fait c'est comme ça
c'est tout
il est froid un mot s'ils veulent être
ensemble et si c'est possible et on ne
peut pas faire tout ce qu'on veut on a
déjà pas de place donc
[Musique]
ce téléphone de chaleur et en plus ça
commence
c'était ou
plus banalement wolof il l'avait me ader
lui au fond du lit leur remettait les
grades su c'était l'autre il ya des sous
le matelas l'opposé vers le mur bon sens
large la réalité du côté de berne est
taillé à même les chargeurs et tout
s'est bousculé
le principe de surveillants référence et
de prendre en audience des détenus
isolés entre quatre murs comme ça ils
peuvent parler couteau
alors comment ça se passe en détention
pour moi
qu'est
ce qu'ils vous ont gardé quand même
trouvé
ok et c'est quoi comme travail sur
d'autres
seront forcées lycée en déplacement mais
n'en sait pas où les voisins
voici une excellente mais
c'est bien parce qu'il y en a ils sont
dans le déni qui ne sont pas la
souffrance des
enfants c'est l'appréhension de près par
ailleurs plus en plus à ce
une façon pour moi de servir à ma façon
c'est vraiment pas mon pays que moi
j'aime bien ce que je fais je représente
même si on nous aime pas trop je vous
présente l'état représente la france ou
quoi
ouais ouais c'est vrai j'en suis fier je
ne dis pas tout le monde mais aussi fait